wait till she makes me a meal i really
can't a local businessman that says he
has achieved the american dream
has also written autobiography about his
journey so that you can enjoy it
and learn from it here's ron cory your
book is called tenacity and it's all
about your life from marine strength
to new york hustle to living the vegas
life right
it is it is all about my it is my life
story in that autobiography yes
if we combine all of those moments in
your life it is achieving the american
dream
achieving the american dream in the form
of the 20 businesses i've started or
purchased
and i cannot give enough credit to
my success came with the help of great
business partners
um i've had three significant business
partners in various ventures
that coupled with having three children
and five grandsons motivates me
to achieve things succeed and provide
for the people i care about that's
beautiful we always have to remember to
attribute our success and our happiness
to the people around us right
it's not all about you that's right
that's right and my support people
i have to thank everyone in my life that
helped me get to where i am
what does the american dream mean to you
can you define it for us because i think
it's a little different for everybody
it is well you know health and happiness
are critical it's not all about money
while it's nice to be financially secure
though
that success comes with making good
choices in life but
that's all worthless without health and
happiness having survived
cancer and covered enables me to do the
things i want to do now
like pursuing a new business like
squarepanda
and as a board member i donate time for
the metro police foundation
and i like to play recreational poker at
the bellagio
in fact i was featured one month
on the cover of card player magazine the
ultra bible
in this country so life today is
marketing my book playing poker and
pursuing some business challenges
but not as heavy as it was when i was
working in multiple businesses at the
same time of course you you experienced
some major corruption you know back in
the day in vegas too
so there were plenty of people trying to
stop you and get in the way but you
you persevered through all of that
they actually encountered a corrupt city
council member
who was a competitor in private business
wow because our council members served
part-time
and he was a competitor in business and
used his power as a councilman
to try to frame me with multiple felony
charges
and that is the centerpiece of the book
and how that developed
and how i overcame it and i think people
will be intrigued
with the somewhat out of the box
thinking
and creativity that i had to employ
to clear my name and
teach him a lesson that he had coming
he's not going to
disclose what we did but it's a great
story
sounds juicy all right get your copy of
tenacity on amazon
and for more information just visit
roncoryauthor.com we'll be right back